[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING IN HINDI]
KASTURI SHAH: Hello, Seekho
provides free English
audio education through the
basic mobile phones, which
has a vast reach
across all of India
to children and
learners of all ages
in underprivileged
circumstances in India.
VAASVI GOYAL:
Kasturi and I really
didn't know each other
before we came to Princeton
and we met at a reception before
we got to Princeton in Delhi.
And we both instantly really
connected with each other,
really liked each other,
and also soon realized
that we were both really
interested in education
and other development work
in India.
We sat down and we kind of
listed all of the problems
that we wanted to
tackle in India,
or more just in urban areas like
where we're from, like Delhi
and Bombay,
and realized education, and
specifically girls' education,
was something we were both
really passionate about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE LANDERS: Princeton
University's Keller Center
offers entrepreneurship
courses for students,
both in the high-tech sector,
social entrepreneurship.
And we also provide
students with a variety
of seminars and workshops
at the Entrepreneurial Hub.
Kasturi and Vaasvi first
came to me in fall of 2014
because they were interested
in using the eLab Incubator.
The incubator is a
program where students
can come to work on
their startup ventures
and we provide advising and
mentorship to the students.
I was really excited
because I wanted
to help them really
foster that idea
and expand and turn
it into a nonprofit.
And they've been doing
an amazing job with it.
KASTURI SHAH: In order to test
our ad-based revenue model
we need to get to a call --
a critical call volume, which
we think is 1,000 calls a day.
Now in order to -- Hello, Seekho
is the kind of enterprise
that exists currently.
The only thing that stops
people calling into it
is the fact that
they're not aware of it.
So our funding therefore
goes towards marketing
and making that awareness known.
And so that's why
funding is so crucial
because we need to market it
to get it to that call volume
to be able to stop
pitching to companies.
KASTURI SHAH: So I'm here in New York
on my own about to give a pitch
to apparently 250-plus investors
and we've got to pitch twice,
four minutes each.
Yeah.
I wouldn't say I'm freaking
out but I'm scared.
So one of Hello, Seekho's
greatest strengths
is its curriculum,
which builds upon itself
and uses positive reinforcement.
The content contains
stories, songs, and poems,
which makes learning fun.
KASTURI SHAH: I realized how much
I actually love pitching the idea
and I think that's partly
because every time we do pitch,
I think we realize how
much we believe in it
and how much we've invested in
it and the impact that it has.
And I think I kind of went onto
the stage with that mindset.
People really appreciated
what I was saying.
A lot of people came
up to me and said, hey,
that was a very good,
clear presentation.
And we've put a lot of
work into the slides.
KASTURI SHAH: We made pretty
big leaps and bounds
in terms of data analysis.
So we have at this point
40,000 phone calls.
So what that means is we
have a huge volume of data
to analyze to further direct
not only our curriculum
but also our marketing efforts.
VAASVI GOYAL: Some of the
really interesting things
from the data
analysis were that we
found that people who
call back to the service
call back an
average of 50 times,
which is a really -- which
is a really good statistic
to know because we
have been around
67 lessons on the server.
So, once we look at
those trajectories,
we'll be able to see
if people are listening
to different lessons each time.
But, like, 50 is just
like kind of the number
we were hoping for in terms of
seeing that kids are learning
from it and it's not
this one off thing
where you call like five or six
times and you forget about it.
VAASVI GOYAL: This has been
one of the most exciting weeks
we have ever had.
The crowdfunding
platform that we're
using to run our crowdfunding
campaign in India
reached out to us
saying that they
wanted to send out a story about
us to the Press Club of India.
And then Kasturi and I
wake up like two days later
and have an email from the
BitGiving person with links
to like 12 different
stories about us
in the biggest
newspapers in India
that we've both
grown up reading.
It was amazing.
KASTURI SHAH: I am about to
post news about the article that
was in the Times of India,
which is India's biggest
national newspaper and link
it onto our Facebook page
for Hello, Seeko.
Then the next day I get --
so we get daily blasts
from the server about the
number of calls per day.
Normally they're
around the 100 mark.
Maybe a little lower,
maybe a little higher.
So I get an email
that says, you know,
they're 26 something thousand--
VAASVI GOYAL: 24,000--
KASTURI SHAH: --24,000 calls.
So I said, I think the
server is malfunctioning.
So I forwarded it to Vaasvi.
I said, you know,
something’s wrong.
And then we check
and we've nearly
run through our
entire coin balance.
It wasn't 24,000 calls.
We had like 70,000
calls in 24 hours.
Just because so many
newspapers covered it.
We now have how many total?
VAASVI GOYAL: Like
around 130,000,
140,000 calls on the server.
It's so gratifying to see kids
from now all over the country,
and not just like
pockets and areas
where we've marketed this
calling into the service
and to see that we can actually
approach advertisers now.
Because we're receiving way
more than 1,000 calls per day,
which was our goal at
the start of the year.
It gives us such a
clear path forward.
It's so clear to us
now what we need to do next
and where we can take
it once we graduate
in the next couple of months.
And so it's been really amazing.
KASTURI SHAH: We were
talking about this earlier,
but we -- to be able to think
that the goal that we set
at the start of the year of getting
to a thousand calls per day, now
is basically achieved.
It isn't really a goal
anymore -- it's kind of part
of the venture's history
is absolutely amazing.
VAASVI GOYAL: Seeing the sort
of success only reaffirms
our commitment to Hello,
Seekho and our desire
to keep on working on it
because it's so exciting
and it's something that
we care about so much.
But, yeah, so that's the plan,
is to go back after graduation
and work on it full time
for a couple of months.
And then, at the same
time, set up the framework
so that other people can
take over the day to day
when we leave.